vous pensez être un pro de google et des
statistiques eh bien c'est ce que nous
allons voir puisque aujourd'hui nous
sommes sur google feu le principe est
extrêmement simple il faut tout
simplement deviner quels sont les mots
les plus recherchés sur google on a
démis la presse vous trouvez la fin
c'était hyper m'a expliqué que j'avais
dit alors rien et je vous montre tout de
suite ces partis ont choisi de catégorie
culture people know who question qu'est
ce qu'on fait et paul quelle phrase qui
commence par je suis trop gros pour les
gens ont le plus tapé je suis trop gros
pour manger hu à vérone et déjà comme ça
je suis trop gros pour avoir une copine
moi c'est triste non non il n'y a pas
beaucoup rire oh la la c'est le
quatrième qu'est ce que je suis doué
pour faire l'amour non pour nager non
c'est pas ça moi le premier je suis trop
gros pour être hipster mais c'est notre
cas recensés je suis trop grand pour
parfaire bucchini est franchement gros
maigres on s'en bat les couilles soulève
est un bikini vous mettez un bikini
[ __ ] comment devenir un hipster là
pour le coup c'est sur leicester
youtuber youtube un astronaute attendu
plus recherchés au moins chercher c'est
comment devenir un député un saint un
juge un leader autrefois un sociopathe à
citoyen américain mais un pas pire
non mais quand je mets deviner sa
domestique et moi est ce que la lune a
alors là je pense qu'hier boîte heures
c'est sûr premier en cinquième puis son
moteur hockey de l'acné on sait jamais
elle a des cratères un atmosphère
ouais [ __ ] de la gravité oui mais bon
là que la lune à jean-jacques non non
[ __ ] qu'est ce que la lune a non un
noyau à dax du vent quelques mois pour
certaines être dicté quoi alors affaires
du pôle comment ressembler à alors là
kim kardashian csu à l'afp jean-pierre
la chambre là je suis surpris que ce
soit ça non à how to look plus petits
fous là
qu'est ce qui se passe si ton micro
ondes c'est ça le truc bien qu on n'a
jamais traduit en fait c'est qu'est ce
qui se passe si tu mets dans micro-ondes
nadal un téléphone c'est sûr y'a quoi il
ya plein de gens qui ont fait ça là ils
pensaient que tu pourrais recharger
nouvel iphone comme ça m dutel la hausse
est de hockey ont cédé à aluminium h et
que ça fait un truc terrible non quoi
nous promet c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
si tu peux me gronde un chat mais elle
est bourrée vendent en fait jamais de la
weed même les français savent plus quoi
faire
aussi rien du tout qu'est ce qui se
passe si tu mets rien du tout aux
micro-ondes ses bonnes questions comment
dessiner un alors là un chat voilà un
chien voilà un cheval voilà at on fait
tout le truc les enfants dessinent un
squeeze amené sais pas c'est quoi la
réponse qu'une rose une fleur un dragon
à la part une personne amenée à guarne
c'est super dur décerné est ce que tu
peux mettre dans le lait à 1 pb non un
retour arrière mais pas sa [ __ ] oui
répond je m'aperçois je suis hyper
content j'ai mal traduites c est ce que
tu peux donner du lait à pas est ce que
tu peux mettre dans du lait aux baleines
nathan le mec il a une baleine chez lui
dis [ __ ] j'aimerais bien le filet
d'huile et dans le doute je vais aller
sur google street view why do ou menace
assez drôle
pourquoi les femmes pour 1 m enfin
dekraai pleure souvent voilà j'ai pas
besoin en plus j'ai toutes les féminines
sur vos droits au rebut ti foule
pourquoi elles sont belles je suis sûr
c'est ça ouais mais là ya pas tant que
ça pourquoi les femmes sont belles la
fin offrait déjà la réponse en vrai
mettez des bikinis
pourquoi elle crie non tâche une merde
de mexico aux éditions claqué en premier
pourquoi les femmes trop couleurs mais
pas pour les mêmes raisons que les mecs
donc ça c'est pas mal pourquoi elles ont
leurs règles à ça c'est intéressant ça
c'est tout ce qu'ils ont entre 8 et 10
ans elle savoir pourquoi elle mettre des
soutiens gorge ouais limite pour quoi
elle parle autant d'extraire une
question est ce que jésus peut voler par
les noms c'est quoi alors mais mais mais
mais mais what
la première réponse c'est quoi est-ce
que j'ai su me mettre au micro ondes un
burrito commenge sens et de recouvrer sa
au mexique + à comment tu fais pour
prétendre être riches qui font genre jeu
sur qui on cherche sow
enfin à célibataire célibataires comme
on dit célibataire c'est sûr [ __ ] j'ai
tout faux j'ai tout faux j'ai tout tenté
ah oui mon premier malade comment on
fait pour quoi faire pour prétendent est
malade [ __ ] oui quoi tu parles en
course tout le monde mais ça ce google
quand tu fais pour prétendre à être
vierge
d'ailleurs je me conduis pourquoi temps
d'être avec mes essais sentent des
épices laïque spices non [ __ ]
l'impasse sur les épices mois place et
perd sa ce jeudi à temps mais j'en ai
dit quoi je te revois en 1er mai et
celle sentent la weed
mais ces craintes et les aisselles
centre lie le curry le café n'a ni le
poisson voileux tacos voilà moi c'est ça
c'est ça moi cette halte à côte
merci à tous je sais que vous aussi
votez pas toucher les fajitas ce sont là
même moderne qui fait que je mange de
moins en moins
j'ai rêvé que j'étais toujours volé
ouais que j'étais déshérités non c'est
sûr c'est un oiseau nom de la merde je
l'avais que j'étais moi je suis choqué
de ménage moi moi je joue est une grosse
merde mais j'ai rêvé que j'étais
enceinte occupait occupait seul hutin
ces mots ça comment tu es un la dre
super glauque un terroriste pardon une
taupe into plutôt ça ça fait chier les
gens ça a un bébé âgé cru ça aurait fait
un zombie un rat une souris ouais moi
j'étais je déteste le goût de la viande
de la viande of mixer sur le rappelé un
mec mais plus tard je déteste le goût de
implose
quand tu saignes et par le coup de talon
mais merde je déteste le goût de la
défaite
c'était quoi je déteste le goût de l'eau
de la bière de la stévia du kof du café
de la wii 2 mais qu'est-ce que ça
t'apporte de marquer sur google je vous
prends pas en fait c'est bizarre comment
se débarrasser de votre famille il y en
a combien saint lô [ __ ] je suis
rassuré et éduquer mon mari que je tente
un pourquoi les gens aiment la
souffrance c'est faux le coma c'est faux
canet en slip c'est faux les chats la
musique la pierre le sexe
il nouera entre pour les jeunes tout ce
qui est bien beau mais quelle question
d'ailleurs question du monde quoi le
mexico derrière elle et pourquoi
pourquoi les joueurs aiment faire
l'amour c'est visible culture peut pas
être froissé les marionnettes lapacho
oui car oui non peut-être pas les
couilles
oui tout faux charles charles aznavour
vue français quoi là même la france
battue mais direct monsieur aznavour
dans les temps pour un chef charles de
gaulle c'est sûr qu'il y est d'accord
maintenant mais cette fois max est sûre
si tu tapes charles voilà le deuxième
c'est de gaulle le troisième set d'amour
voilà voilà monsieur c'est parce que
c'est un truc anglais donc tu les prends
cette offre ça prend pas en compte
raciste j'ai rigolé des bars est ce
qu'il est possible de voler voilà en
4ème position et ce qui le pousse et de
tragique halloween voyez c'est dans
toutes ses dents tous de vivre sur mars
[ __ ] j'ai pendant des mois les cheveux
noirs rayon des teintures à une teinture
pour cheveux noirs je veux l'acheter
oui bien sûr alessi merci je savais pas
comment faire j'ai dû chercher sur
google arrêté d'utiliser google pour
économique c'est qu'à chaque recherche
de google ça consomme l'équivalent d'une
heure d'une ampoule ou la summer amiable
en scène un faux comme moi est ce que
quelqu'un a déjà été enceinte à l'école
captain america c'était quoi d'antan est
ce que quelqu'un déjà été cloné
c'était pas mal est ce que quelqu'un
déjà été tué par un chat a déjà été
mangé par acer pour des actifs et déjà
des c'est encore bon et juste la
patineuse sur google faisait pas mais ça
vous a plu on a fait des découvertes de
malade je pensais pas qu'ils ont tapé
des trucs pareils vraiment je suis
bouleversée pourquoi je suis bouleversée
n'était pas le cas mais je vois aussi
c'est gratuit on est si vous avez réussi
en plus c'est dur très dur anglais
français des fois
on cherche pas la même truc selon les
pays à la 113e poussé vidéo portez vous
bien tu retournes pis